jd he's embarrassed but he loves o.j
simpson uh let him explain here you go
yeah he likes oj in movies and he feels
guilty about it
oh gee didn't do that good a job in the
movie
listen to jd what do you like about o.j
simpson's performances
in the naked gum it's just it's just
funny he's
he's funny and charismatic and uh
and uh you know i'm not exactly proud of
it
right uh i'm not happy with myself about
it
and then well you know what don't do a
[ __ ] bit
of like jd loves o.j simpson
whatever dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] jd loves
o.j simpson even though he
[Music]
[Music]
i made a big bloody mess out of two
innocent people
but jk
he's just funny in the movies
uh he's only he's not exactly the lead
in the movies just
apart uh but yes i see nordberg i don't
see
o.j simpson you see the laughter you
laugh and
you're in joy and you forget about what
he did
right it's nordberg it's not oj that's
that's basically
anyway jd you're having a hard time with
the movies i love nordberg
not oj you feel oj did a good job as
nordberg
in the movies yes yes and it bothers you
because you don't want to like oj but
you like it
right when are you watching those movies
again and again and again they're the
naked gun movies they're some of the
greatest movies to ever be made i don't
know what you're talking about oh boy
i gotta tell you i mean i showed
i don't think i've seen it more than
once and i didn't even know oj's
character was nordberg i mean
uh i didn't know the character's name
either yeah
well listen i i don't know what to tell
you
you watch godfather too jay simpson
uh film fest i'm not doing one either i
was asked
a question i got back let me ask you
this do you think norberg should get his
own movie
now oj nordberg would you watch that
he's really funny jd that's what
that's what they pay me for he likes it
so you would not attend the nordberg
film festival
[Laughter]
if i told you jd what
jd please he can't stop laughing jd
he loves his ball
if i told you that we're gonna have a
nordberg film festival you would attend
i don't know i i'd have to see you all
shows up
i think that you should put together the
nordenberg film no
he's not he's only in two movies would
you invest
what if i told you we could invest what
if i told you you could be the director
of nordberg the movie i can't i can't
you have to work with oj but you'd be
working with nordberg
you will not do it look i think you
could get oj on the phone for that
project
oh yeah
[Laughter]
honest answer
you